Lisa e took issue Lou tak is passionate
about fashion growing up in the Canadian
Arctic she dreamt a one day bringing in
with traditional designs to European
catwalks I was younger I would always
watch the the runway models and when I
saw fashion show and Nikoli at the high
school with the traditional clothes and
new styles I thought it would be nice to
show Erica are close in on traditional
clothes and updated with the fashion
world today las September she enrolled
in the fur design program at the Arctic
College in her native iqaluit to learn
fashion design for thousands of years
her ancestors have used animal fur
especially seal skins to make clothing
but Lisa's dreams of making a living as
a seamstress in the designer are now
threatened by a public relations war
unfolding thousands of kilometers away
innocent life this successful
anti-saloon campaign has galvanized
public opinion and forced the European
Union to introduce a ban on all sealed
products technically the Inuit of Canada
and Greenland who still depend on seals
for survival are exempt from the BAM
which comes into effect this summer seal
is one of the most important species for
a new it is I could say it's more
important than polar bear and more
probably more important than than
terrible or some other wildlife species
in Europe because the seal is used in
hole as food source as a clothing for
survival in the time pass for arts at
crab for our shelter the Inuit
subsistence seal hunt is different from
the commercial hand that has drawn the
ire of animal rights activists in
wintertime seals live under the eyes
coming up to the surface to breathe
through holes formed in the cracks
between the constantly moving ice fields
annoyed hunters scoured dozens of
kilometers of sea ice in search of seal
breathing holes
then they have to wait motionless in the
biting cold and wait and wait and wait
it's a lottery run by mother nature
because even if the seal does come up to
the breathing hole there is no guarantee
that the hunter will get his prey in the
spring when seals come up on the eyes
hunters have to creep up as close as
possible one well-placed shot is usually
enough to dispatch the animal without
causing it too much suffering with food
prices in the Canadian Arctic up to
three or four times higher than in the
south the Inuit rely on seal meat to
supplement their diet Hunter's often
share their catch with the rest of the
community those too infirm or too poor
to go hunting themselves before the band
was introduced to the hunters used to be
able to sell the seal skins to
supplement their meager incomes now it's
not even worth taking the time to remove
the blubber seal skins are often thrown
out or become food for dogs and cross
the band has dealt a harsh blow to an
already impoverished population in the
last two generations the inglot have
gone through dramatic and often painful
changes to their lifestyle in many cases
they were forced to abandon their
nomadic camps for settlements that
seemed to have all the trappings of
modern life but few of its economic
opportunities and lately they've had to
deal with the consequences of climate
change the threatens to alter the
physical environment they live in the
European Union ban has already brought
an almost total freeze to the sealskin
market last year at the fur auction in
North Bay Ontario not a single pelt was
sold out of 11,500 were harvested by
Inuit hunters in Nunavut and that has
prompted Senator Celine a review i't
from Canada's french-speaking province
of Quebec
to lobby the federal government to
compensate Atlantic coast fishermen and
Inuit hunters for lost income well get
the three years ago before all this this
war under the seal hunters are started
they were getting one hundred dollar for
each skin right now they get maybe
thirty dollars so of course this is the
income did you at this time of the year
in order to proceed to other income like
on the East Coast it's a lobster here it
would be fishing but you don't fish now
the European Union ban has steered up a
lot of anger in Nunavut I think the CF
and people didn't do enough research or
that they're just channel find a way to
make money and I'm just wondering why
like I feel why are you I don't know why
are you bothering us and we're not doing
anything this is art
yeah it hurts because my ancestors they
were I just get so mad at though because
my ancestors they live surviving on the
land and surviving on seals during the
summertime and if it wasn't for the
seals then maybe they'll like starve or
whatever I just I don't
it's hard to say in English I know a lot
of elders are hurt by this
we appreciate like we're allowed to
respect our elders and this is really
hurting my ancestors cuz the seals been
with us for to this day yes well I just
this is the way we live this is the way
we always lived Diana who came to the
Arctic hoping that by passing on her
skills as a fashion designer and
seamstress she can help Inuit women
escape the grinding poverty it makes it
very difficult for the Inuit and general
to understand this concept it makes it
difficult for us who wants to help the
Inuit in developing their own place in
this world to make them understand that
they have to accept a decision which has
no sense
sickly I feel upset myself I feel it's
very hypocrite to want to save an animal
while you're killing a culture but
nooner would authorities are worried
that the seal hunt ban is just the
opening salvo in a cultural war that has
pitted urbanized Westerners against East
Coast fishermen and Inuit hunters my
worst fear is that in addition to ban of
sealskin products in European countries
that this band could have also other
ripple effects for other wildlife
species in Nunavut other than silicon
products that would have a different
devastating effect on economic
opportunities especially for smaller
communities that has unemployment as
high as sixty to eighty percent of
unemployment in small communities
selling self skin products even though
it's very minimal has a big implications
for community for a family that doesn't
have any other income Canada's federal
government has launched a challenge
begins the band in the world trade
organization in the meantime the
government of new node is looking for a
long-term solution we are working very
hard in trying to find other markets
other than European countries for
example were definitely interested in
looking at China and we're also
definitely looking at Russia and other
than European countries and we're also
going to be looking at seriously within
Canada
Lisa Ischl attack thinks the panel
rights campaigners and European Union in
pieces simply need a crash course in the
realities of life in the Arctic I would
take them camping and then I would love
to take them camping summertime me my
family we always go camping we go to our
grandparents can go to my honors cap I
just want to show them how we live how
my ancestors lived how a cynic slip up
here and during the winter and cold days
we do need zeal to survive still they're
not in danger or anything it's not like
we're keeping them in a farm and giving
them fat and then killing them and then
making money off them it's just that's
just how we live and she hasn't given up
on her dream just yet oh I want to have
my own fashion runway but if I do get my
own fashion runway I'm gonna have like
all my friends I want them to be moths
I'm gonna have or I wish to have the
short skinny one or the short chubby
khan and
the big girls or the tall ones or
regular size not just one size I want
like from short
big for short small to talk big